[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Sonntag die Fußball-WM hat begonnen mehr
dazu nicht nur um Sport mit Norbert
Lehmann ein schönen Abend noch von mir
sondern auch eine Nachrichten der Blick
auf unsere Themen
durchwachsene Bilanz zwar gelingt auf
dem Weltklimagipfel der Durchbruch beim
Fond für ärmere Länder sonst aber
überwiegt die Enttäuschung
pompöse Feier zum Start der Fußball-WM
2022 Gastgeber Cutter zeigt sich betont
weltoffen
und Abschied von Sebastian Vettel der
viermalige Formel 1 Weltmeister beendet
nach 299 Rennen seine Karriere
[Musik]
einer Volk wurde bei der
Weltklimakonferenz erzielt so die Bilanz
ansonsten herrscht an nüchterung nach
dem Treffen in Ägypten nach rund 40
Stunden Verlängerung einigten sich die
fast 200 Staaten auf folgende Ergebnisse
beschlossen wurde ein klimafond für die
Bezahlung von klimaschehenden ärmeren
Ländern aber wer in ihn einzahlt und wem
das Geld zugute kommt muss erst noch
erarbeitet werden das 1,5 Grad Limit bei
der Erderwärmung wurde immerhin
bestätigt doch die dafür notwendigen
Maßnahmen zur Reduzierung von CO2 fehlen
so wurde beispielsweise der Ausstieg aus
fossilen Energien wie Öl und Gas nicht
beschlossen über die Ergebnisse der
Weltklimakonferenz Marko eine letzte
harte verhandlungsnacht und die
Ansprüche sinken erst an den
Liegekomfort dann auch an die
Schlusserklärung der Hammer viel am
frühen Morgen
Kohle Energie soll zwar schrittweise
heruntergefahren werden doch die von der
EU geforderte klare Absage auch an Öl
und Gas fehlt das aufgrund der Blockade
von einigen großen Emittenten und Öl
produzierenden Staaten überfällige
Schritte zur Minderung und zum Ausstieg
aus fossilen Energien verhindert wurden
ist mehr als frustrierend von einer
wahren Abwehrschlacht gegen die
Ölstaaten reden Beobachter das Ergebnis
ein Rückschlag war es zwar nicht aber
eben auch kein Fortschritt diese
Konferenz hier war ein Pflaster auf eine
klaffende Wunde
mit den Maßnahmen die hier beschlossen
wurde ist es extrem schwierig die 1,5
Grad noch einzuhalten einen unerwarteten
Durchbruch gab es aber doch ein
Hilfsfond für Schäden und Verluste durch
Klimawandel folgen in diesen sollen die
reichen Staaten die die Erderwärmung vor
allem verursacht haben einzahlen das
Geld fließt immer dann an arme Länder
wenn diese von Stürmen Dürre Fluten oder
dem steigenden Meeresspiegel getroffen
werden eine fast 30 Jahre alte Forderung
der Entwicklungsländer wird nun erfüllt
dass man anerkennt hier dass Menschen
entschädigt werden müssen für
Klimakatastrophe und Klima Folgen ist
total wichtig dass man sich aber eben
dann auch in dem Zuge
nicht hat einigen können der
Klimakatastrophe so schnell wie möglich
in einer zu setzen das ist richtig
dramatisch und das betrifft uns alle die
Details des Fonds werden in einem Jahr
bei der Klimakonferenz in Dubai
verhandelt Knackpunkt China und die
Golfstaaten weigern sich einzuzahlen
könnten also auch dann wieder lange
Nächte werden
so wollen die Staaten also die
Erderwärmung begrenzen wie viel jeder
und jede einzelne zum CO2 Verbrauch
beiträgt zeigt sich alleine schon beim
Streaming also beim Schaum
beispielsweise von Videos im Internet
oder beim Schreiben von E-Mails wie
klimaschädlich das ist zeigt Ihnen
könnte man das CO2 sehen dass ein
Computer verursacht ist würde ganz schön
dampfen eine E-Mail z.B nimmt im Schnitt
einen Netzwerkkabel weg von 15.000 km
heißt mal eben Daumen hoch zurück
bedeutet zehn Gramm CO2 zusätzlich wir
haben mittlerweile Konversationen wo
wegen Banalitäten 20 E-Mails hin und her
gehen oft auch noch an einen Verteiler
von 10 20 Leuten vielleicht ein Hinweis
eine E-Mail hat ungefähr CO2 Abdruck wie
eine Plastiktüte knapp jede zweite
E-Mail so die Schätzung ist zudem eines
BAM also eine überflüssige Mail
insgesamt verursacht das Internet nach
den USA und China die meisten
Treibhausgase in den vergangenen zehn
Jahren hat sich die in Deutschland
gemessene Nutzung des Internets
verdreißigfacht 100 Milliarden Gigabyte
waren es 2021
wie groß das Sparpotenzial bei einer
bewussten Nutzung von Handy PC oder
Laptop wäre darüber denken auch die
meisten Firmen kaum nach
im Officebereich klar wird auch mal
gefragt können wir das Licht ausschalten
oder so aber das Thema PC Nutzung
E-Mails und so das ist mir eigentlich
jetzt noch nicht untergekommen dass das
großes Thema ist für betriebliche
Optimierung dabei sind Videokonferenzen
oder Livestreaming Ware Energiefresser
alle dafür nötigen Server Router
Computer zusammen erzeugen 205 Gramm CO2
pro Stunde ein einfacher Tweet schnell
getippt ist sogar mit 264 Gramm dabei
immerhin halten die meisten Smartphones
inzwischen länger und müssen zum Teil
reparieren wahr sein das ist nachhaltig
genauso wie jede E-Mail die man nicht
verschickt
17 Uhr und zwei Minuten der Anpfiff mit
der Partie gegen Ecuador ist in Katar
die umstrittene
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft gestartet
eingeleitet mit einer bunten
Eröffnungsfeier vor 60.000 zuschauernden
im albaid-stadion nördlich der
Hauptstadt Doha nach der heftigen Kritik
im Vorfeld präsentierte sich der
Golfstaat betont weltoffen mit Themen
wie Diversität Inklusion und Toleranz
über die wm-eröffnung berichtet Wolfgang
zimmermann
es kommt anders schwebt wie ein Gespenst
das Maskottchen der WM LAE übersetzt
supertalentierter Spieler es soll die
fußballfreude wecken
die Show wirkt weniger bombastisch als
gedacht vielleicht auch weil europäische
Stars nicht mitmachen wollten
musikalischer Höhepunkt threemas
der katarische Sänger Fahrrad
aus Südkorea
Auftritt von us-schauspielermorgen
Freeman mit einem Vertreter der jungen
katarischen Generation dem
körperbehinderten Social Media Star gar
nicht da spricht er über die hohen Werte
von Toleranz und Diversität wir sind auf
dieser Erde damit Völker und Stämme
voneinander lernen können
an mehreren Stellen der Show stellt sich
Katha immer wieder ganz bewusst in einer
Reihe mit anderen WM Gastgebern dann ein
überraschender Moment
die Herrscherfamilie gewährt Einblick in
ihrer Familienalbum der Emir spielt
Fußball mit Freunden seltene Bilder
einer sonst Kamera schon Familie
und dann die Rede auf die nach der
Kritik an Katar alle gespannt warten der
Emir begrüßt Menschen verschiedenster
Herkunft aller Nationen Religionen
Orientierungen
[Musik]
ab heute Abend werden wir 28 Tage lang
und mit uns die ganze Welt diesem großen
Festival des Fußballs beiwohnern in
einer Atmosphäre menschlicher und
zivilisierter Kommunikation
ein Appell an ein freundschaftliches
Miteinander eine Show die viel auf
Themen wie Toleranz setzt vielleicht ein
erster Schritt vielleicht auch nicht
Endor ist für uns Gulli wir haben es
gerade gesehen bei der Eröffnungsfeier
ging es also um Inklusion Diversität
Toleranz aber wie ist das denn
einzuordnen gerade nach der Kritik an
Kata
ich würde sagen das kleine Emirat hat
sich sehr gut in Szene gesetzt das hat
vor allen Dingen sein Selbstbild in
Szene gesetzt das darin besteht ganz
unterschiedliche Menschen
zusammenzubringen miteinander zu
versöhnen das Emirat sieht sich ja sehr
als Friedensstifter und in dieser Rolle
wird das tatsächlich auch vom Westen
gebraucht ob es um den Frieden geht
zwischen den Palästinensern und den
Israelis um den Frieden in Afrika oder
den Frieden des Westens mit Iran der
spielkatar durchaus eine gewichtige
Rolle und all diese Botschaften die
wurden interessanterweise verkündet vor
dem sautischen Kronprinzen und
Premierminister Mohammad Windsheim man
ein ehemaliger Gegner der vier Jahre
lang dieses kleine Emirat unter Druck
setzte mit einer Blockade mit einem
Imago der aber heute anwesend war und
die Botschaft ging natürlich auch an ihn
eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen im
gleichen Atemzug wie universelle Werte
beschworen wurden wurde auch dafür
plädiert dass jeder das Recht habe
seinen eigenen kulturellen Weg zu sehen
und wie nimmst du vor Ort die Stimmung
war heute am Tag der Eröffnung
ich würde sagen gemischt also in den
Fanzonen ist tatsächlich einiges los vor
allen Dingen dank der
lateinamerikanischen Fans dank der
fanshos Asien oder Afrika dort wird die
WM hier ja auch deutlich positiver
gesehen das wird positiver berichtet
aber in weiten Teilen der Stadt habe ich
heute mehr leise Töne gesehen also es
ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel los
gewesen insofern gemischter Eindrücke
danke schön für die Eindrücke goldene
atai
zeitgleich zum Eröffnungsspiel in Katar
haben im nordrhein-westfälischen Herne
Menschen mit einer ungewöhnlichen Aktion
gegen die wm-protestiert in einem
Fußballstadion wurden 6.500 mit Sand
gefüllte Fußbälle platziert sinnbildlich
für die vielen ausländischen Arbeiter
die auf den wm-baustellen gestorben sind
am Abend leuchteten 20.000 Grabkerzen
auf den Tribünen
in der Ukraine ist das von Russland
besetzter tumkraftwerk saporizia wieder
unter Beschuss geraten die
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
meldete mehrere Explosionen auf dem
AKW-Gelände ein von russischer Seite
veröffentliches Video soll den Beschuss
des Kraftwerks zeigen Russland und die
Ukraine geben sich gegenseitig die
Schuld an den Angriffen laut IAA ist
keine radioaktive Strahlung ausgetreten
einige Gebäude seien jedoch beschädigt
das türkische Militär hat kurdische
Stellungen im Nordirak und in Nordsyrien
angegriffen nach eigenen Angaben
reagiert die türkische Regierung damit
auf den Bombenanschlag in Istanbul vor
einer Woche für den Sie die kurdische
Terrororganisation PKK und die syrische
Kurden Miliz ypg verantwortlich macht
beide weisen das zurück Glück
die Zeit der Abrechnung so heißt es bei
der türkischen Regierung sei gekommen
Verteidigungsminister AK bestätigte
Luftangriffe auf 89 Ziele in nordzügen
und Nordirak man habe eine große Zahl
von Terroristen getötet
dieser Operation gegen die Terroristen
wurde sehr umsichtig geplant und
erfolgreich ausgeführt
angegriffen wurden zahlreiche
Ortschaften in Nordsyrien und
PKK-Stellungen in Nordirak dabei sollen
nach kurdischen Angaben allein in Syrien
31 Menschen getötet worden sein die
Türkei beruft sich auf das Recht zur
Selbstverteidigung sie macht die PKK und
nordsyrische Kurden Milizen für den
Terroranschlag mit sechs Toten am
letzten Sonntag in Istanbul
verantwortlich beide Gruppierungen
bestreiten entschieden jede Beteiligung
die türkische Offensive gegen Kurden in
nordsylien war schon vor sechs Monaten
angekündigt worden dann aber wegen
widerstandsauswashington und Moskau
verschoben worden Präsident Erdogan soll
den Angriff am Donnerstag auf dem
Rückflug vom G20-Gipfel in Bali befohlen
haben zuvor war er dort mit US-Präsident
beiden zusammengetroffen die
Luftangriffe so glauben Militärexperten
könnte der Auftakt zu einer neuen
Großoffensive der türkischen Armee in
nordsylien werden in der Vergangenheit
war es so dass in solchen Situationen
die Zustimmungswerte für Präsident
Erdogan stets gestiegen waren das könnte
auch jetzt Teil des Kalküls der
Regierung in Ankara sein
nach türkischen Angaben wurden bei
kurdischen vergeltungsangriffen am Abend
im Grenzgebiet bei killes mehrere
Polizisten verletzt
sie wollten einen unbeschwerten Abend
verbringen dann aber erschoss ein
Angreifer fünf Gäste eines Nachtclubs in
der US-Stadt Colorado Springs 18 wurden
verletzt warum der 22-Jährige in dem bei
Schwulen lesbischen queren Menschen
beliebten Club sofort nach dem Betreten
um sich schoss ist unklar er wurde von
zwei Gästen überwältigt und von der
Polizei festgenommen die Attacke geschah
in der Nacht zum Transgender day einem
Gedenktag für die Opfer von
transfeindlichkeit die Ermittlungen
laufen
seit dem Sturm seiner Anhänger und
Anhängerinnen auf das us-kapitol im
Januar 2021 durfte Donald Trump nicht
mit twittern jetzt wurde die Sperre für
das Konto des früheren US-Präsidenten
bei dem Kurznachrichtendienst aufgehoben
der neue twitter-chef Elon Musk hatte
bei den nutzenden darüber abstimmen
lassen
51,8% waren dafür Trump selbst aber
hatte im Vorfeld erklärt er habe gar
nicht die Absicht zu Twitter
zurückzukehren
so nach der wm-eröffnungsfeiern kann er
nun zum Eröffnungsspiel ja vor 60.000
zuschauernden der Gastgeber mit seinem
WM-Debüt der Gegner Ecuador ja und der
wurde seiner Favoritenrolle gerecht das
erste Tor dieser Weltmeisterschaft
erzielte der überragende Valencia in der
16 Minute
cooles Meter 15 Minuten später sein
zweiter Treffer zum 2:0 entstand ein
echter kopfballhammer Kata enttäuschte
nur wenige Torchancen wie etwa dieser
Schuss von mundari in der 86 Minute
zum DFB-Team die Spannung im deutschen
Quartier steigt Mittwoch das erste
Gruppenspiel gegen den Film maligen
asienwelten Asienmeister Japan heute ein
besonderes Ereignis ein fröhliches
Training zusammen mit jungen
Fußballerinnen aus Katha und anderen
Ländern
dieses gemeinsame Training ist Teil der
sogenannten FIFA community-events an
denen sich alle wm-nationen beteiligen
das Ziel der Aktion besteht darin im
Gastgeberland gesellschaftliche Projekte
zu fördern ich glaube für uns ist es
auch immer sehr schön den Leuten in
Kontakt zu treten sich auszutauschen die
Freude die die uns alle irgendwie lenkt
durch den Fußball mit anderen Leuten zu
teilen teilnehmen am Training konnte
nach seinem viralen Infekt wieder Niklas
Füllkrug an sie fliegt kann also
aufatmen hat er doch nun alle Spieler
gesund und munter zur Verfügung die
heute unter anderem übrigens auch einen
gemeinsamen Torjubel geübt haben
[Applaus]
Abschluss der Formel 1 Saison mit einem
versöhnlichen Abschluss einer großen
Karriere der viermalige Weltmeister
Sebastian Vettel wurde beim Großen Preis
von Abu Dhabi 10 im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes sein Schlusspunkt
Sebastian Vettel holt zum letzten Mal
alles aus seinem Boliden heraus
Feinstaub hin Feinstaub her in seinem
299 Rennen zeigt der viermalige
Weltmeister einige gute Manöver wird 10
und holt noch mal einen WM-Punkt ich
glaube ich darf mich sehr sehr glücklich
schätzen dass ich sowas erleben darf
noch mal zum Schluss und ähm hab
versucht es zu genießen so weit es geht
Mick Schumacher wird 16 in seinem
letzten Rennen für Haas Zukunft ungewiss
Weltmeister Max Verstappen gewinnt zum
15 Mal in dieser Saison volle clair und
Teamkollege Peres Verstappen wird weiter
seine Runden drehen den dritten WM-Titel
fest im Blick
das riecht ja bis hierhin das war's vom
Sport danke Norbert und wir blicken
am Vormittag vor allem in Thüringen und
Sachsen Schnee und gefrierender Regen an
der See und im südostenschauer sonst
auch mal Sonne bei 0 bis 11 Grad
das heute schon mal können Sie im 21 und
45 sehen mit Christian Sievers und
Morgen begrüßt Sie an dieser Stelle mit
reserin auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]